today our show teeth into the me creates
a series of ones and zeros and we're the
two big V rule rule as we talk about the
matrix rebooted what no today I'm fat
man I'm Batman
[Music]
welcome to that man that man Kevin Smith
I'm mark Barnard uh the matrix rebooted
what they announced last week somebody
now don't know if is accurate did it
come out of studio system anyone verify
this mark I was exclusive to The
Hollywood Reporter Warner Brothers
confirmed in some fashion that they are
indeed planning early stages of another
film set in and around or over or
through the matrix universe I'm just
taking a moment to put my finger right
on the pulse because I don't know what
two weeks before they announced this I
heard of a little motion picture
announced name of Jay and Silent Bob
reproduced my movie makes fun of movies
like this while being one of those
movies I'm going to try I've got KP
needed to like a big fat pig that any
event
everyone's rebooting everything dude and
I never imagined they'd [ __ ] touch
this because if this [ __ ] ain't
brilliant art what is and I ain't talked
about the secretary but I'm talking
about the first one see but I think for
me is nothing sacred
I mean no no I'm not mad yeah my here's
my complaint now and I'll let you say
your [ __ ] okay let me get those out
because the bugs [ __ ] outta me get after
crop why reboot [ __ ] same universe seek
walled everything doesn't have to be a
[ __ ] reboot you're gonna lose anybody
by going hey guess what we're making on
another Matrix movie like just same
universe don't [ __ ] be like here's
what you didn't know last time you know
why cuz that [ __ ] was brilliant
brilliant dude matrix one of the
greatest [ __ ] motion pictures ever
made one of the most inventive
screenplays ever [ __ ] written what
are you gonna do to reboot that you know
what I'm saying like and maybe I what I
might have said this about here's where
I'll give you a room for doubt - says
it's about dawn the dead back in the day
but why why would you have someone
get it is brilliant alone and then Zack
Snyder made a brilliant [ __ ] movie so
I'm not saying it can't be done I'm just
saying keep it in the [ __ ] universe
man
neo happened right [ __ ] Trinity
happen
[ __ ] Morpheus all that [ __ ] happen
now go and do whatever you want like
because they said at the end of it like
get the end of the third one if I can
remember us bleeding by the end but I
think they were like you know it's kind
of like Val circa languages all happen
before it all happen again you didn't
give me any to get the impression like
it's done forever those two [ __ ]
microchips met on a bench and we're like
well till next time
like what isn't gonna happen again so
they promised it was gonna happen again
just let it be that don't make it this
brand new [ __ ] thing where it's like
he's a guy named me unless this is the
[ __ ] like remember in the room of the
gark attacked was like this is the
hundred eighty eighth iteration of this
[ __ ] scene and this time like he just
looks like Michael B Jordan and [ __ ]
fine but keep them tied don't ignore
what went before that Ryan's put it on a
t-shirt or a bumper sticker don't ignore
what went before that works for a lot of
things not just a Matrix movie it does
history [ __ ] like that so that pin the
writer/producer first guy on the
Avengers just did ready player one he's
doing it he is writing and sort of
overseeing I'd liked his stuff I I had
him once at a screening for something he
was also the the creator of alphas a
little television show that I was not
right around right but what could I my
know-how is sort of brain works and I
think that there's nobody wants this to
be good more than he does his fan he's a
fan and he did go on a sort of series of
tweets once that news broke saying
nobody is mentioning reboot or remake or
rehash beyond this press thing like
we've never said those words good you
know what he also said if I was going to
recast Keanu Reeves I'd cat canneries
yeah that's good cool so I don't I don't
I feel like there's a world in which
there's been a bit of rumour milling in
the way that the Internet does rumor
mill [ __ ] Milne email me mail me that
because they're in early talks we
Michael B Jordan yes to star that
there's a world in which this is either
the continuation of the matrix where did
black neo and for those of us who give a
nipple Godard yam you think insinuation
who can go deep into the Arcana to
remember that Will Smith was offered the
role of kneel before Keanu Reeves
absolutely right and turned it down
because he didn't understand it cuz the
major that that's funny that's kind of
wise like I didn't get it I just didn't
I didn't get what they were saying about
Django to it yeah like he just did a
kind good I think it was also like he
didn't want anybody to see angry slave
Will Smith that that was bad for his
brand let's not fall down that rabbit
hole yeah that's that's a totally
different rabbit hole done a couple
years ago um but yeah he was the rector
of the game that's whatever um and I
think you're right um many things I'm
right that you're wrong yes Will Smith
as the peace watch he's like [ __ ] are
you still like watch the show now
they're talking about me [ __ ] what is
talking about me because that's how you
turn into the road beyond his [ __ ]
web TV or some totally nineties like
he's calling Jada on his [ __ ]
princess phone come over I've got a long
tour don't get stretch to the TV I want
to come down to the Batcave I gotta tell
you some [ __ ] that these guys are
talking about I don't envy Zach pan like
look it so there's the woman which like
it is the extension of it that's what I
wore that it is a prequel in which
Michael B Jordan would play young
Morpheus oh and maybe there's a story of
how you liberate Trinity oxide uh that's
good what is that what if we go why
didn't you say that I'm not here [ __ ]
telling people what to do he has the
solution is that it I mean I've heard
I've heard around town that every studio
is looking for their robe one there like
find me this thing that slots into a
franchise we already have that's a new
story that doesn't [ __ ] with anything on
the side but lets us sell a bigger Bob
you just changed the matrix for me now
I'm now I'm like that's a [ __ ] noble
effort to tell the Morpheus story yeah
that would be kind of badass that would
be [ __ ] excellent like
you smile it is messy you can fight it
like that you know why you can't reboot
something if you're telling [ __ ]
story about yep that's in cannon in
cannon a like [ __ ] when they put it in a
cannon and could maybe make us forget
about the matrix revolution nothing
could make me forget about I would like
to sure would like to I do forget
periodically and then I'm like you know
what maybe it wasn't I watched a gun
like um but but you know what they're
allowed to do that those guys get a pant
those the Wachowski sorry mother get a
pass from now until the end of time yes
because the matrix is that [ __ ] broom
yeah that brilliant and you don't even
get into like I'm a big fan of Cloud
Atlas you I'm a big fan of speed racer
what I am the show's over
we're done I am a tough look if there's
a I mean there's there's things about it
that I don't like there's ambitions but
I've never seen another movie like it
you know what good point and there's
there's a bit of sort of like mythical
moviemaking towards the tail-end where
like speed is racing and he's losing
it's a [ __ ] rocky fight where he's
behind the wheel of a car and it has
muscular and as robust and by the time
he wins that last race spoiler speed
Reese who wins the race
you know like you know what [ __ ] nice
job and I did like all the Racer X stuff
- hey brother yeah yeah John Gomez path
yeah I just don't need the monkey in the
trunk but I'd take that but yeah that
was it was a ballsy [ __ ] movie it
really it looked like a cartoon come on
um see how quickly it turned around and
I was like look Speed Racer and then
yeah second I have a lot of flipping
this if it's the Morpheus story take my
money take his money I'm gonna borrow
some as mine for he give yours my so I
could give you the rest of his money cuz
that's a good [ __ ] idea that is
brilliant
please make that now you got me all
excited for a movie may not exist but I
hope it does yeah I mean there's no word
which house keys are involved or even
involved in the way that like I would
love them to be involved oversee but
like if you're making the Morpheus movie
I'm good again and not saying like they
can't do it there were geniuses but that
premise
good idea even in the hands of an idiot
that might be a good me yeah like
Morpheus breaking Trinity out of the
matrix and then stealing them in the
commissural ike
make it make it a [ __ ] ideas i
[ __ ] come you said all those words
just made me go also we get forgot about
to the book of magic next word we got
the thing yeah I can use encounter this
I want to see this Matrix movie man I
hope it's what you say [ __ ] you have a
good idea I do it Vera don't you look
you watch the guy go from I don't know
so guy going we'll wait a second and
that's without any help from them knows
from you hold on so there you go saying
like they don't have to sell me any more
Warner Brothers I'm sold
we got it jack then and I trust that guy
geez I'm telling you I like a lot of
this stuff and he also really work on
like principes back in the day he might
have one of the names on his first
credit was Last Action Hero
he wrote that script yeah so he was one
of those like I wrote a spec script he
was wrong as I just got out of film
school Million Dollar Baby
I got a madam at I think I was at the
Battlestar Galactica Paley Center at the
ArcLight and he said hi and I think it
was like didn't he write The Incredible
Hulk movie the one the good one yes he
didn't rent angley one yeah he was the
one that was like in the Marvel you know
when he breaks college watch this [ __ ]
anyway break story that Norman good
movie it holds together well good flick
it I've watched that within the last
year and it still [ __ ] works yeah
hold up about a weird
airbrushing of Tim what's it say Tim
Roth's chest to make him look muscly I
love that well yeah cuz he a gets weird
so that wasn't real don't think so give
me go back and look at it I'm like not
then people look like it's more like a
regular guy with muscles airbrushed on
him so I was like oh yeah
look like I know that fight at the end
was just like two video game characters
I can go [ __ ] man it was like hald first
abomination and granted it wasn't Harlem
it was very obviously Toronto but that
was like this is [ __ ] crazy
and what's her [ __ ] it was it was Emma
yeah was that it was a Betty I just I
love that beat when he's in like Mexico
and looking for pants and he's like
moths stretchy
masterji pants there's a chase scene
2:30 boom Isabella's I just like seeing
favelas and they're not Keep Calm all
the time they're like saying
Nebuchadnezzar but fun water paint it
down um all right [ __ ] I'm in I mean
I'm in the bag this like you see they
put the logo on top of the moon nice job
guys give it up for JC and Angela it
made the show look classy Oh shiny
though there it is man [ __ ] matrix is
coming and we're happy about it first I
was confused and now very happy about a
movie that may not be the movie but I
want to see your version it better be
that I want to see the hundred Knights
iteration Warner Brothers The Matrix all
right that's it Batman Batman chemistry
I'm not Bernard Fame come back and watch
us again yeah same that time same
pehchaan spawn guess I come or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
[Music]
you
[Music]